we got this big story that that's been
trending today i think there's like
hundreds of thousands of tweets about
tucker carlson saying he's being spotted
by the bottom administration
there's there's reports coming out there
like not even fox news believes it
but i i first of all this is a huge
story but when you were talking
you're just talking about technology and
giving up all of our security and
everything
tucker mentioned that a whistleblower
contacted him
and expl and told them information about
a story that could have only come from
his texts or his emails
but think about that right we we we view
using
our cell phones as a convenience we use
we see our emails as
a convenience but it's also normal and
now we don't realize that
we've given up some of our security in
exchange for using text and email like
we didn't realize that wasn't that was
an exploit
the nsa or your political rivals could
use against us yeah
i mean i was on a show last night when
he said this and
i mean just knowing tucker was obviously
telling the truth tucker's not a person
he would never
introduce anything on a show that it
wasn't real research and he wasn't 100
confident what he was saying he's not
just lingering something in front of
someone's faces
there's no effort to tantalize the
public with what he's saying and you
know it's a big story but it's also
common sense
you know especially with this government
right this totalitarian regime of biden
where we can't even say things that are
true you can't even tell the truth when
you're censoring a lot of people for
literally
telling the truth of what happened to
them right i i do
kind of like some something feels off
about saying the totalitarian regime of
biden because while i do recognize
there's certainly a lot of
authoritarianism
they're going after the grannies from
january 6th giving credit for that to
biden
well it's not well so when you say
solitary regiment biden like you know
he's the puppet
to the puppet he's just put there right
he doesn't know what he's doing like
obviously he's not the mastermind of the
biden regime the biden regime is just
like it's jill
yeah it's it's not even jail i mean
these people need to realize these
people
for years the people that became
president are
selected by oligarchs you know they
decide
they want to be president obama was
picked you know they had them run
they're in with the media the media is
is just
you study propaganda you don't recognize
it when it's right in your face right
mainstream media is literally meant to
control the way you think i mean it's
called tv programming for a reason
it is programming your mind uh you know
you know you can take up an um that's
not a conspiracy theory you can take a
basic marketing class and learn that you
know like
certain colors make you react a certain
way music you know subliminal messaging
in stores buy it buy it buy it you know
we had uh bannon on the show and a lot
of people
in our audience were surprised at what
bannon was saying like he said tax the
rich
he's like these people are ripping you
off we gotta tax the rich and people who
watch this are like whoa
the media said he was like far right he
was a fascist he was a white supremacist
sounds like an occupy wall street guy
right right that's the rich yeah they i
mean
they believe everything i mean there are
people that are so invested and
they the funny part is they are the ones
that call everybody nazis and they know
so little
about nazis they know so little about
germany they don't even know what
fascism is they don't even know they are
the fascists when they say censor at
censor they don't understand it because
they're not meant to understand it
because there's been this sort of
rinsing of history
and they just think everything they
don't like is a nazi and they don't know
actually what the nazis are and it's
you know how did hitler accomplish what
he accomplished right because he
controlled the media
he controlled the media you couldn't say
anything and that's exactly what's
happening a glowing profile piece about
joe biden
jill biden um and people go okay well
why was trump attacked because he wasn't
in the establishment the oligarchs
didn't pick him
right we didn't get into a meeting and
say we want our guy in the office if
they had
they would have said he was the best
person that looked like we said about
obama you could not
find bad information on obama right
because that's
that's they control the media and they
control people's minds and there are
people that are walking around in
america right now and they genuinely
believe that i am a black white
supremacist like they're that far
deluded like it's like at the dave
chappelle sketchup yeah it is and they
believe it because that's what they're
told every day by the media they watch
it on candace oh and she's just a black
white supremacist she just
woke up one day and said i want to help
create a society that i can't live in
yeah that's how can i help oppress
myself this is
it's it's the perfect example of
cognitive dissonance and how how are we
supposed to
progress how are we supposed to solve
our problems when you have an entire
faction that bases their world view off
of paradoxes
like there are a bunch of like like you
being a black white supremacist
it's not a possible thing it's like
clayton bigsby was a joke
yeah they literally believe it yeah they
do they literally believe it they
the joke has become her life parody has
now become real life right
and you know the first thing is it's
it's
it starts i think with taking power away
from the education system i am now a
huge believer in homeschool
homeschooling and like i know you were
just showing me your mom does math
videos i'm a huge believer now you know
they're
they're there's a constant effort to
dumb children down in school and i'm not
talking about a little bit i'm talking
about kids cannot do
basic math equations um and yet they're
learning critical race theory they're
learning about emotions and how to just
react without actually knowing why
you're reacting
they know nothing about history but love
to throw out terms like nazi and fascist
and
they're just emotional babies and so
this sort of blubbering of the american
mind can only
be reversed if you take take your
children on the education system
and go back to where this country began
plymouth you know when they when they
landed in plymouth rock
it was a bunch of moms being like i'll
take monday you take tuesday it was
homeschooling and it was about community
outreach and organization
i definitely will not put my child
through the public school system
in america and the private school system
is questionable now too because
the government the federal government is
overreaching there's all these different
requirements
now even if you want to homeschool
because kanye you know i was with him at
the end of last year and he wanted to
start a homeschool thing and he was
talking to me about all of the
roadblocks
in california to prevent that from
happening because the government wants
your children they want to make sure
your children are dumb
think about what's going on with all the
critical race theory stuff these these
school board battles
then you have at the same time one of
one of trump's campaign uh promises for
in 2020 was school choice we see a big
push from conservatives about
parents having the right to choose where
their kids will go to school maybe a
voucher program
and the democrats say it's racist to do
that no you can't allow that because
then the rich people are gonna do this
that or otherwise
then we see what they're doing they're
it's not this is this is the trick that
the left is doing right now with
critical race theory they're saying
no one is teaching critical race theory
because no one is showing the book white
fragility which is critical white
studies
nobody is reading kimberly crenshaw
you're all mistaken what they're doing
is
they're applying critical race theory
into everything else yeah
then they're indoctrinating kids with
psychotic nonsense
and then when the parents complain what
just happened we saw this in loudoun
county they arrested one guy
because he was just standing there
saying i want to speak and they're like
the events over you're not allowed
yeah he's like well i i was told i was
allowed to speak and then they they
arrest him no
he didn't get arrested i think he got
detained and received a summons so
i think that's technically an arrest one
guy got into a fight yeah
but this battle is going to be big you
know yeah but it's also like what
it's i'm always amazed when i go around
and i you know get speak on stage the
number one question i get is what can we
do what can we do it's like
it's your children and they're being
preyed upon by predators it's it's like
going around and have people ask me hey
candace like i went to the playground
today and a man
showed my child pornography what what
should i do it's like
what that's literally what's happening
with them they're showing children
pornography and parents are like i
called the administration what do you
mean you called them and she called the
cops you know like teacher are not
teachers not immune
from pressing charges against teachers
for doing crazy things and
if you're telling me that you if you
took a [ __ ] to the playground in a
random stranger because that's what
these teachers are they're random
strangers right they're random strangers
that have gone through radical
um the radical education they're also
the dumbest people by the way people
that get education degrees it's
fascinating thomas soul has a book
um called inside the education system
the lies the dog
the dogma and the indoctrination and he
talks about how
in terms of like their placements in
their universities
the dumbest are people that get
education degrees which is really
fascinating right
um and so you're getting these people
that are not the brightest but are
convinced of their own intelligence
because they're being handed these
degrees and acolytes and they go to
teach like
about the kids you went to school with
like people that became teachers they
were really nice like for at least
high school like they were the nice kids
but they were not the brightest in our
school
they were like the you know c-minus kids
they wanted to computers and they should
like great uh we need teachers i support
teachers i love teachers
but they they are convinced of their own
education and whatever they're told to
teach they teach
right and and i i know i'm painting a
broad brush here but
so they go in they they teach your kids
all the stuff you don't know them
they're strangers and yet you're too
fearful to remove your child
from what has obviously now become a
predatorial situation
right you're preying on kids you're
teaching them race you're teaching them
how to hate one another you're
separating kids and saying you know why
are you embarrassed about your white
privilege this actually happened in new
york school
like go around the room and talk about
why you're you should feel guilty for
being white
your children are being attacked that's
a predator remove them that's i mean
you're a parent forget it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you